vu l'ambiance actuellement sur les
réseaux sociaux ne dit pas non à un
petit guide pratique alors quand des
journalistes du guardian dévoile le
contenu de 300 pages de ce qui est
présenté comme un guide à usage interne
pour les salariés de facebook on le lit
attentivement
dans cet article on apprend par exemple
quelle serait la politique en vigueur en
ce qui concerne les appels à la violence
ainsi ces publications pourrait être
toléré lorsqu'elles concernent des
personnalités publiques
s'il s'agit d'une formulation figurative
et si la personnalité en question n'est
pas directement tagué sur la publication
alors cette dernière ne serait pas
supprimé nous pensons qu'il est
important d'autoriser des epa critiques
concernant des politiques et d'autres
personnes publiques mais cela ne
signifie pas que nous autorisons les
gens à les harceler sur nos applications
reste que la définition par facebook
d'une personnalité publique mais pas
très clair et qu'il reste délicat de
mesurer l'impact de milliers de
publications sur une personne autre
aspect abordé dans ce guide interne
celui du soutien des organisations
interdites comme par exemple les groupes
terroristes facebook interdit la
justification d'actions violentes mais
autoriserait des messages jugés comme
factuel l'exemple utilisé dans le guide
est le suivant la phrase l'ira a été
poussé à la violence par les pratiques
brutales du gouvernement britannique en
irlande serait autorisée tandis que
l'ira avait raison d'utiliser la
violence pour combattre les pratiques
brutales du gouvernement britannique au
cours du 20e siècle serait interdite
des subtilités qui vont jusqu'à modéré
lusage des emoji dans réaction des
publications qui concerne des
organisations interdites
ce guide de 300 pages servirait de
support aux modérateurs de facebook et
malgré ces révélations du guardian la
politique de modération du réseau social
reste opaque
déjà parce que ce guide n'avait pas
vocation à être publié officiellement
pour éviter de donner aux utilisateurs
malveillants les clés pour contourner
les règles en vigueur
d'autre part car le service externalisé
de modération ne parvient pas à régler
toutes les situations outre les
accusations récurrentes de censure
certains critiquent les agissements de
facebook en matière de modération
justement
cette semaine les ong reporters sans
frontières a déposé une plainte en
france contre le géant américain pour
pratiques commerciales trompeuses
facebook on one side size d'un côté
facebook dit qu'il s'engage contre la
circulation des discours de haine ou de
fausses d'information est en réalité les
théories du complot les discours haineux
circulent massivement sur le réseau
social et speech siècle hated massive
les fans de sochaux mené pour
l'équilibré entre lutte contre les
discours de haine et défense de la
liberté d'expression est toujours
difficile à trouver mais en conservant
l'opacité sur ces méthodes et en s'étant
fait épingler pour des mesures motivé
par ses propres intérêts économiques et
idéologiques facebook peine à convaincre
ses prêts de 3 milliards d'utilisateurs
jadis plateforme adulée pour sa
nouveauté facebook est désormais de plus
en plus critiqué la régulation
arbitraire des contenus explique en
partie une forme de désintérêt beaucoup
ont compris que le réseau social est à
utiliser avec modération